Tyrese uh he did like the Dame time at
the uh in the game being a vet like when
you see like the new kids doing that or
like you know NBA players looking up to
you in that way like how does that make
you feel seeing like someone do that I
mean it's when you uh I learned as a as
a kid you know when you dish it out you
got to be willing to take it and for as
many times as I've done it to people you
know I can't be upset when um somebody
else does it you know what I mean I
think that's also so
um a sign of respect and acknowledgement
for you know knowing my history and
knowing what I do and uh you know I I
didn't mind it um was what it was I just
I've also known that you know when you
having your moment is it's important to
be careful and to to be humble when you
having your moments cuz you just never
know how the tables turn and when they
going to turn so um I respected it you
know I didn't think we shook hands after
the game and I I wasn't moved by it left
right great thank you
sure